[Music]
[Applause]
we bring in the aforementioned Michael
case that the first time you've heard
the call since you made the call Michael
no I heard it last night because we
played it a couple times coming back
from break in the later innings
uh when you know that there's history
that can be made how do you treat each
at bat as the announcer every time judge
comes to the play
you know it became a little trying for
everybody that I'm sure for the viewers
as well Dan because you know you're
doing television and you know that this
is going to be a standalone at bat if he
hits the home run so you've got to like
layer all the important parts of what's
coming up and you know we're also
welcoming in uh National audience that
was joining us on ESPN and on MLB
Network so there was a lot of uh that
bookkeeping to do so after a while it it
got really really old what kind of
criticism was attached to this home run
Chase
in terms of my calls or the Home Run
Chase I think everything that's involved
in it I think there are people that
probably have wanted to free their
conscience that hey I fell in love with
bonds and McGuire and Sosa and now I can
move that to the side and we got a clean
home run champ or you know you're
breaking into programming nobody cares
about Aaron judge or the Yankees so I
not that you can control any of that
well it's interesting Dan we live in a
world I think where negativity really
has a louder megaphone than anything
positive so you know a lot of people
were saying and it was spurred on by
Roger Maris Jr who was a real gentleman
that this is the real record it's it's
not the real record even Aaron judge
says it's not the real record the real
record is Barry Bonds but the beauty of
sports and the beauty of those numbers
is that you can actually make the
decision for yourself if you think that
it's judges 62 that ring Supreme then
that's what you should believe but to
say that it is the official record I
mean there's a record book that has
Barry Bonds at the top of it so that was
certainly uh something that we heard a
lot of and then you know especially
during the Saturday broadcast and when
we kept breaking college football Sean
McDonough uh a friend of mine made a
snarky comment as well one time we cut
into NFL live in the first game
yesterday and they cut in for Kyle
hagashioka's at that so you know I guess
everybody that wanted to see it was
probably watching yes or the MLB Network
and those that didn't want want to see
it didn't want to see it so they didn't
want to be bothered with it how big a
record is this though
I think it's a big record because it's
the American League record so you don't
have to like fudge it and you know say
the clean record or since they've been
testing or anything like that you know
number 61 almost as a romantic feel to
it and sports not just in baseball a
movie by Billy Crystal 61 and that
number stood the test of time so when
you break that number after 61 years I
think it does mean something I really do
does Roger Maris go away now
you know what it's funny I asked a
couple of people that does that diminish
what he did I don't think so because it
was so dramatic when he did it and it
was a Chase between he and Mickey Mantle
so it captured the imagination of New
York and certainly the country as well
and they were beating Babe Ruth's record
and that's probably one of the all-time
great names in all sports so I don't
think he goes away but I do think it
takes a little bit of the shine away
from the fact that you know he was the
American League home run leader and
those that believed that the guys in the
National League did it with Peds or
whatever they could always go back to
Paris well now you can't go back to
marriage you really have to go back to
judge so I think it takes away a little
bit
and listening to your call now this
wasn't a no doubter with judge and you
let it breathe a little bit because you
don't want to have warning track power
and you've made this call that you think
it's going to be this Majestic this is
62. this is the Home Run so what was the
strategy there as as that ball is in the
air it almost felt like you took a
breath and and waited to actually see
what was going to happen well I'm glad
that I was on TV and not doing the the
game on radio like John because when you
say deep to left you can take a pause
and let the picture tell the story and
then once I saw that it was gone uh then
I said soaring into history but uh yeah
that was not that was not the the home
run that you really wanted on that call
because you know if it was one if it was
like what Giancarlo Stan hit the other
day 457 feet I mean you could serve a
meal on that and still make the call but
this one this one was a a little tricky
and I'm just glad I didn't stumble on it
but I did give it time to breathe
because I want to make sure that it's
gone well remember when Maguire broke
the record it was a bullet it was just a
bullet you couldn't even get you know
it's high it's it might be it could no
it was like it's gone it's over then
what do you do
and that you know what Dan that was
almost like the um the 61st in Toronto
that was kind of a bullet too and
sometimes that's good because you can't
get into all of these you know grandiose
nonsense that you know you think that
people want to hear it's just boom it's
a home run call but uh this was like a
little bit between 70 uh between 60 and
61 somewhere in the middle of those two
calls he's Michael K the Yankees
play-by-play announcer for uh yes
Network what impact will this season
have on Aaron judge future as a Yankee
well I know it's going to have an impact
on his checkbook for sure so he turned
down 213 million and I would assume Dan
that he probably made himself over a
hundred million dollars more so that's
significant now how does that impact uh
signing with the Yankees I I say he's
still the odds on favorite to go back to
the Yankees but I think it opens up a
lot of other bidders I mean the San
Francisco Giants from what I've heard
would really make a run at him and
that's his hometown team uh you have to
wonder what Steve Cohn and the New York
Mets be interested when when the Yankees
were in Boston I heard Whispers that you
know the Red Sox are getting nervous
that their fans think that they're
trying to become a small Market team
after trading mookie bets maybe they
would make a run as well kind of the
reverse uh curse of a Bambino but I
think there will be bidders out there
and I he's played it so beautifully Dan
and close to the best so I don't know if
he's going to take a little less to stay
with the Yankees but I will I will tell
you this if it gets silly you know
everybody has said well the Yankees have
to sign them no matter what well that's
not how the Yankees do business it's out
of no matter what situation if it gets
to be a line that's crossed that they go
well we don't want to give him 11 years
they'll they'll walk away and I think
that if they undercut him he'll walk
away so I think it's it's going to be a
very fascinating
conversation between the two sides come
come November what what would his legacy
be if he left the Yankees after this
season
you know I hear that on the radio show
so much it's like it's it's callers call
in and it's almost like they're afraid
to fall in love
you know you know it's like a Summer
Romance where Olivia Newton-John's going
to go back to Europe and then you're
stuck in greeceville so it might have
been a great summer but you really
appreciate it as much unless you stay
with that person forever uh I think I
think fans are torn they really are I
think it would still be a magnificent
season but if he doesn't come back as a
Yankee I think in Yankee War it will
probably
be tamped down just a bit because he's
no longer fans will think he's no longer
one of us
I always wonder and and we've seen
players who don't fit into New York
their personality doesn't fit
um
judge I don't know him
but he seems to be
you know pretty even Keel about most you
know he showed frustration throwing his
helmet the other night which I was
surprised at but for the most part
he seems to have a temperament that can
deal with all of this how important has
that been for this season and really the
maturation process of him
well I I think if you went to a
laboratory and created the perfect
player for New York it would probably be
Aaron judge you know he says the right
things he deals with the media very very
well uh he works from the Derek Jeter
Playbook where he's not going to give
you all that much but he's going to give
you enough time that you feel that you
just got enough to do your job uh
doesn't treat people poorly I've never
seen that and one thing that I've
noticed about him Dan he's so
unbelievable with children and he's
unbelievable with children when even
when they're not cameras around you know
I took my seven-year-old son to spring
training this year and he got a chance
to meet him and you know he gets down he
literally gets down on the level of
child and is looking in their eyes and
talks to them and really asks them
questions and a lot of athletes don't
have that and if they do it's eye wash
but this guy really seems like he he
cares about kids and and the impact that
he has on children so he's been he's
been amazing he really has been amazing
and uh he he the fact that he didn't
Flinch at all Dan when he turned down
213 million dollars a lot of guys would
have put a lot of pressure on themselves
you know betting on themselves you've
heard that phrase so much now well he
bet on himself and and he really he won
big and that there's something to be
said for that when you do it in New York
remember the first 13 games of the Year
Danny had one home run so everybody's
going oh it's affecting him well it
didn't affect him the only the only time
I ever saw him be affected by pressure
this year Dan was what you just
mentioned first game of the doubleheader
yesterday when he slammed his helmet
into the bat rack I've never seen that
from him in six years I think it was
starting to get to him because it was an
individual achievement and he's a total
team guy
who do you expect to play in the World
Series
I I think it's going to come down to the
Yankees and the Astros and the American
League can the Yankees solve the Astros
I don't know the Yankees have a really
tough road ahead of them man because
they don't have a they don't have a
closer I mean they're gonna have to do
you know closure by committee that's
really hard to do over the month of
October
um I I think you know how do you bet
against the Dodgers so right now I'd say
the Dodgers and the Astros but if the
Yankees somehow figure out the bullpen
aspect of it I could see the Yankees
knocking off the Astros is the the
hatred for the Astros over
not New York
and probably not in L.A either not in
L.A not in New York but I think around
the country yeah probably Wayne's just a
little bit but uh in New York I mean
they'll just break into the uh Altuve
chants and you know it's like Red Sox
fans or even anybody in Boston during a
Bruins game the Yankee Chan comes up so
I don't think the uh I don't think
Yankee fans will ever ever forget that
I'll leave you with this I'll give you
the future of Aaron judge
or the future of shohei Otani
ohtani's younger
so I'd probably take the future of Otani
because he's younger and he's making 30
million off arbitration and you know how
I Love Money Dan so I think that judge
will get about 40 million a year and I
think ohtani when he becomes a free
agent after next season will probably
command 50 million dollars a year
oh my God how would George Steinbrenner
deal with today if if he came back and
you say you know George that guy's gonna
cost you 50 million dollars a year
I think he had a way to he had a way of
adapting Dan I think he would have put
away for sure and I I think the team
would be completely different you know
how I think he's done a great job
running this team but he's very he's a
very business-like guy and that's the
way he runs the team but if George was
running the team right now I'm sure that
Bryce Harper would be on the team and
Manny Machado would be on the team all
the big you know shiny items on the on
the shelves George probably would have
got to come to the Yankees how how close
was Seinfeld to capturing Steinbrenner
um probably not that close uh he was not
goofy like that you know he was
impetuous but he wasn't goofy you know
the the Larry David voice and everything
kind of caught the timber of the voice
but you know he wasn't running around
screaming for calzones or anything like
that so I don't think they totally got
him but in a comedic sense they
certainly uh uh you know I've been told
that in comedy he just kind of expand
expand expand to make it funny so they
kind of expanded off the germination of
a character but that that wasn't George
there wasn't that much goofiness Michael
great to talk to you again and great job
with the call and good luck in the
postseason thank you so much Dan that's
Michael K yank Yankees play by Playboys
for uh yes Network